c'est toujours leur de bari ça avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
c'est quand j'étais petit j'avais été à
saint-tropez et comme en effet
saisonnier partir en vacances lorsqu'on
travaille et une en fait pendant les
vacances
donc du coup mon grand père il avait
pris une caravane dans un camping
s'appelle les prairies de la mer à côté
de saint tropez c'est sublime
et franchement mais on s'est éclaté
c'est mieux meilleur souvenir parce que
c est m
les campings il vous jure tester c'est
génial le camping c'est le kif
c'est simple c'est nature s'est pas
prise de tête
on s'amuse on rigole on fait toutes les
conneries affirmé camping
je prône le camping j'attends mon pire
souvenir de vacances d'été c'est pour il
sait quand tu partie à mes
grands-parents visiter à un point de la
france que je citerai pas parce que
c'est très beau et c'était tellement aux
enfants à visiter des châteaux ou mon
avis mais c'est c'était l'horreur des
villages avec des grosses pierres mais
c'était à la base j'avais l'impression
qu'ils avaient un fantôme qui allait
sortir dans chaque flux mon avis c'était
horrible pour amy lang wassim plus
jamais retourné
[Musique]